les gardes-côtes italiens n'avaient
jamais intercepté autant d'embarcations
depuis le week-end ils ont repéré une
cinquantaine de bateaux comme celui ci
tous surchargé dix mille migrants ont
été secourus en quelques jours seulement
le ministre italien des affaires
étrangères réclame le soutien de
l'europe
winnie tout et guérissent emergency nous
devons dit il affronter cette urgence
pas juste en tant que pays
mais en tant qu'union européenne le
chaos en libye inquiètent
particulièrement l'italie qui juge que
les pays du g7 comme le canada qui ont
combattu kadhafi ont tous une
responsabilité envers ces migrants 400
seraient morts lundi noyées lors du
naufrage au large de la libye
clairement la fermeture des frontières
ne décourage pas des réfugiés prêt à
mourir en mer pour sauver leur famille
selon l'onu la moitié des migrants de la
méditerranée fui les violences en syrie
en erythrée en somalie au soudan en
libye au nigeria l'autre moitié fui la
misère et un avenir bouché en tunisie en
algérie au sénégal et dans les autres
pays du sahel
ce qui arrive en europe témoigne d'une
traversée de l'enfer et une peau
il nous parle dit-il de trafiquants de
drogue et qui bat et tue les gens
pendant la traversée du désert
des passeurs sans scrupules qui ont
aussi commencé à tirer sur les
gardes-côtes pour voler les bateaux
remorque
car il manque d'embarcations pour
traverser le flot grandissant de
migrants depuis 2010 leur nombre n'a
cessé de grimper pour atteindre 219 me
l'an dernier à travers tout ce désespoir
le souffle d'un nouveau né qui avait
jours en mer le bébé et la maman et le
papa sont tous vivants et en assez bonne
santé
il prie maintenant pour ne pas à être
renvoyés dans leur pays l'erythrée ici
sophie langlois radio canada montréal